et pour la récompenser le ciel qui était
fort dans les cinq lui envoie une pubis
de timbre prime qui lit non André
Brassard se passionne pour le théâtre
depuis qu'il est enfant et il vient
d'avoir 22 ans quand en 1968 les belles
soeurs révolutionnent le théâtre
québécois avec l'auteur Michel Tremblay
il veut mettre en scène au milieu qu'il
connaît et comme il l'entend
je pense qu'il faut le faire c'est
malhonnête de le faire autrement parce
que moi il y a rien que je trouve plus
outrageant que de voir sur une scène un
plombier dire toi et moi la
collaboration des deux hommes s'étendra
sur près de 40 ans brassard fera la mise
en scène de presque toutes les pièces de
Tremblay il travaille aussi d'autres
auteurs classiques telles euripides ou
contemporains tel Jeunet et Beckett ça
fait passer le temps
[Musique]
le permettez
en 1999 un accident vasculaire cérébral
le laisse à moindry physiquement mais sa
vivacité d'esprit demeure comme le
montre son travail sur haut les beaux
jours de Beckett et la création en 2009
de la pièce une truite pour Ernestine
chouchoir de Thompson Highway une sorte
de Tremblay autochtone ce sera sa
dernière mise en scène l'année suivante
André Brassard fait de sa biographie une
sorte de testament il y parle
ouvertement de ses excès passés de sa
consommation de drogue et de sa
condamnation pour détournement de
mineurs au lancement il en profitera
pour saluer ceux avec qui leur a partagé
sa passion pour le théâtre merci de la
générosité merci du talent merci merci
de l'ouverture d'esprit merci de
de m'avoir suivi dans mes folies
Geneviève Wasselin Radio-Canada Montréal